do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video today I want to talk about Sir
Bronn of the Blackwater this is a
character that has essentially been in
service of House Lannister ever since
the first season of the show ever since
he was first introduced at the
crossroads in he has went on to save
Jaime antarians life on multiple
occasions now he was always compensated
for his services in some way but right
around season fours when bran was told
he would eventually get a castle of his
own however we are now at the final
season and bran has yet to receive a
castle now for those of you that might
not remember let's go back a couple
seasons that way you know exactly how
all of this started as you all know when
Joffrey was assassinated at his own
wedding it was Tyrion Lannister who was
thrown into the cells under suspicion of
committing the crime when it became
obvious that he would not get a fair
trial he figured he might as well let
the gods decide his fate by requesting a
trial by combat this would not be the
first time we have seen Tyrion do
something like that in fact it was bran
who went on to save Tyrion during his
first trial by combat so he was hoping
that bran could do it again
however Cersei knew that would happen
since Cersei desperately wanted to see
Tyrion dead she went ahead and made bran
an offer he could not refuse
Cersei made arrangements for Bronn to
marry lawless Stokeworth in hopes of
keeping bran from fighting for Tyrion he
was happy about that arrangement because
lawless only had one sister and that
sister was not able to have any children
so Bronn knew that if her sister
happened to die in some freak accident
then his new wife would be next in line
to inherit her family's castle
now although bran was very happy about
the new arrangement he did go to the
cells anyway just to see what Tyrion
could offer him the reason why bran did
that was because Tyrion had always said
I will double whatever anyone is
offering you why did you bother to come
here
you once said if anyone ever asked me to
sell you out you'd double that price the
two wives you won't talk to consoles one
of each you do everyone should remember
how that season came to an end
Oberyn Martell goes on to fight for
Tyrion then Tyrion ends up killing his
father and leaving for eso's now this is
where things actually start to get kind
of funny because bran continues to get
reassured that he will get a better wife
and a better castle than originally
offered but that is yet to happen during
season five lawless is talking abroad
about their upcoming wedding but they
are interrupted when they notice Jaime
sitting by the castle Jamie needs Bronn
to come help him get Marcela out of
Dorne and back to King's Landing Jaime
also tells him he will no longer be
getting married to lawless because
Cersei went ahead and made new
arrangements for her to marry someone
else
Wallis will be marrying sir Willis Brack
name we made a deal your sister and I
would have advised against that how is
this good for me cause you're going to
come with me and help me with something
in quarters and when we return I'm going
to give you a much better girl and a
much that's a console that obviously
makes Bronn very angry but Jaime assures
him that he will get an even better wife
in a better castle if he comes and helps
him get Marcella back he does agree to
go and they do find marcela but
unfortunately she dies before she ever
makes it back to King's Landing
once again bran does not receive his new
wife or his new castle so now we go to
season 6 this time Jamie takes Bronn
down a river run so they can take back
the castle for the phrase the blackfish
now has Riverrun but the phrase still
had that merit Ollie Jaime and Bronn
arrived to the castle under siege this
is when he reminds Jaime you still owe
me a new wife and a castle and once
again
Jaime says he will deliver what he is
owed expect to command all deny mr.
forces before long
you can be the right hand I lost
you promised me a lordship and a castle
and a highborn beauty for the wife and
you'll get all three a Lannister all
groan say it don't [__] say they
eventually do take back Riverrun but
bran never does receive anything from
Jaime so now we go to season seven this
time bran helps Jaime sack Highgarden
they defeat the Tyrells and they take
all their gold and after the battle he
starts to complain about not getting
what he is owed Jaime does give him a
sack of gold but bran still wants the
castle interestingly enough this is when
bran turns around and says that he once
I guard him he reminds bran the Tyrells
were allies at the nars Targaryen
as soon as Dany learns Highgarden was
sacked by the Lannisters you do not want
to be there when she shows up otherwise
she would burn you alive as you all know
they eventually do run into Daenerys
Targaryen this is when broaden loses the
second gold that was given to him by
Jaime then of course bran saves Jaime
from getting killed by drug on now Jaime
definitely owes him something big
because he just saved his life once
again so now we finally get to the final
season a Game of Thrones
we see bran in the very first episode
when Qyburn gives him the crossbow
Qyburn says Cersei wants to hire him and
she will give him everything that Jaime
and Tyrion could not he will get a
lordship a castle and a highborn bride
now he isn't about to fall for that so
easy because the last time Cersei said
that she ended up breaking their
agreement that was when Cersei made new
arrangements for lawless Stokeworth to
marry someone else but Qyburn assures
him that it was actually Jaime who did
that and not Cersei that gives Bronn
even more incentive to want to kill
Tyrion and Jaime he does eventually show
up in Winterfell to discuss other
options what the Lannister brothers
he says Cersei offered him Riverrun but
he will give Tyrion the chance to double
the offer bran knows that Cersei will
not win the battle but he still wants to
get what is owed to him one way or
another this is when Tyrion offers
Highgarden which was the castle bran did
one right after he helped Jaime Sackett
however once again Jamie does not want
him to get that castle but it really
doesn't have a choice because bran might
kill him now it's getting very obvious
bran is very sick and tired of the
Lannisters they say they always pay
their debts but bran has been owed a
castle for a very
time it's crazy when you look back and
see how many times this has been brought
up this has been a major section a
bronze story for over half of the show
he was told that he would get a castle
in season 4 season 5 season 6 season 7
and now season 8 as you can see by the
title of the video I do not think bran
will ever get a castle from one of the
Lannisters and here's why it's actually
kind of simple look at the current
situation the Lannisters are in all of
them are on their way down to King's
Landing to take care of Cersei what are
the chances that any of them survive
long enough to give Bronn his castle he
told them not to die because he would
come looking for them after Danny wins
the battle now Jaime most likely won't
make it out of King's Landing ever again
as soon as Danny finds out he left
Winterfell to go to Cersei she might
want him dead because that would be seen
as a betrayal also something I talked
about all week as I doubt the Narus or
even Tyrion survived the entire show so
how could bran get his Castle if all of
them are dead
Cersei will die one way or another Arya
Jaime Danny grey worm Jon and so many
other characters want to see Cersei dead
this is something bran already knows
will happen which is why he came to
Tyrion and Jaime to make another
arrangement Cersei will no longer be an
option for bran now most fans assume
Jaime and Cersei will die together
either Jaime kills her then Jaime
somehow dies or Danny burns down the red
cape when both of them are inside I
actually thought Jaime would die during
the Battle of Winterfell since he was
somehow able to make it out of that
battle I really don't see him making it
out of King's Landing
so right there goes most a bronze
options he will not be getting anything
from Cersei or Jaime because they will
be dead that basically only leaves
Tyrion as his only way of getting what
is owed well if you have been watching
my videos then you would know that I
also believe Tyrion will die before the
show comes to an end
he should have already told Danny
everything Varys has said he is already
endangering her life because he's
keeping his mouth shut Varys has already
indicated that he wants Danny dead but
Tyrion isn't saying anything to her
about that that right there could get
him killed alone Tyrion will not be able
to give him hi garden without Danny's
blessing the last thing Danny cares
about right now is who gets Highgarden
all of her friends and dragons are
getting killed her advisors are turning
against her she no longer has the better
claim for the Iron Throne
not to mention she needs to win the
battle without getting killed danny has
all this other stuff to worry about
before she would even consider giving
Highgarden to someone she doesn't even
know that's the Lannisters debt and
right now the Lannisters are not looking
like they are in her good favor the only
way I see him getting a castle is if he
gets it on his own which basically means
he would have to take one from somebody
once most of the main characters are
dead and damn near all the soldiers are
dead after the battle he might be able
to walk in somewhere and take their
castle without much resistance that's
about the only solution I see let me
know what you think happens how do you
see bran ever gettin Riverrun or
Highgarden like I said I think Cersei
Jaime and Tyrion will all be dead by the
end and even Danny might die tragically
so I don't see any other solution for
sir Bronn of the Blackwater he had a
very good run while it lasted but he may
ultimately end up exactly where he
started with nothing he should be
thankful he's even alive after all the
dust settles from all the battles over
the years anyways I want to thank
everyone for watching today's video
and I also want to thank everyone for
supporting the channel I hope you all
have a great day I'll see you again very
soon bye
[Music]